where do you uh work Peter it doesn't
really matter I uh I don't like my job
and uh I don't think I'm gonna go
anymore well our culture is the most
popular Pastime as we know is
complaining especially about
stressed out our second favorite hobby
is to come up with trendy new labels for
common human experiences what if we
could whine about our stressful lives
while also inventing a new label for
something people have always done that
would be the modern uh dream that's the
holy grail and that's what brings us to
the hot new trend called quiet quitting
this is a major topic conversation on
Tick Tock especially where people are
too burned out to do their jobs but not
too burned out to record Tick Tock
videos talking about how burned out they
are so here's one viral Tick Tock video
uh giving more details about this
revolutionary New Concept everybody's
talking about quiet quitting and how
it's the new
negative Talent crisis I think it's a
good thing the youngest Generations at
work are rejecting the idea of hustle
culture or framing your entire life
around some dream job with quiet
quitting you're doing what you're paid
for and not more
and it's about setting boundaries I see
this as a healthy Evolution that can
actually equalize the employee employer
relationship more first of all doing the
bare minimum at work is not some unique
quirky new approach to life we don't
need a label for it it's called lazy
you're lazy and you're stupid second um
if if you want to do the bare minimum
that's fine that's uh that's mediocrity
if you want to live a mediocre life
you're welcome to it
many people before you have chosen that
path and many people after you will do
the same that's why it's mediocrity and
if you're doing the bare minimum at work
refusing to go above and beyond and not
pursuing anything else notable with your
life then you will be unsuccessful and
again mediocre we do the bare minimum
sometimes people die you will not
flourish financially or in any other way
being lazy will extract a payment from
you whether you like it or not and what
you are giving up in exchange for ease
of life is any chance of doing anything
notable interesting or great with your
life
chosen one because the notable
interesting and great things are done by
people who give more of themselves than
is required you want to be a quiet
quitter fine don't come around later
complaining about your lack of success
don't become envious of the people more
successful than you you want it to quiet
quit Okay you wanted to put in less
effort you aimed low and you got what
you wanted you have no right to resent
people who aimed higher than you third
and final Point related to the first two
points I am not suggesting that you
should stay forever in a job you hate
pouring yourself into it year after
miserable year if you if you hate your
job and you feel unfulfilled by it if
you feel that it's not making use of
your talents if you think it's a dead
end Etc then go chase something better
if you just don't want to work at all
then you're a lazy overgrown child
as long as you maintain that attitude
you're destined as previously discussed
to be a mediocre failure and a disgrace
and an embarrassment to your family and
everyone who knows you but if you're
willing to work and yet you feel that
your work right now is wasted or futile
or pointless then go and pursue a new
opportunity what matters is whether
you're doing work that is Meaningful to
you and which utilizes your talents
skills and efforts and it's a lot better
than being a lazy bum
also known as a quiet quitter is that
dark spot on your face still bothering
you or what about the liver spots on
your hands neck and chest well now you
can watch them disappear safely and
quickly in three quick minutes
introducing the genucel Dark Spot
Corrector there are three step three
minute dark spot luxury system does
exactly what it sounds like by using
their crystals
microdermabrasion before the Dark Spot
Corrector and finishing with a touch of
the collagen building genucel 15 you'll
see the dark spots disappear before your
very eyes but don't take my bird for it
if you're not blown away with results
you'll get 100 of your money back no
questions asked so go to genucel.com
Walsh YT order the new dark spot
treatment system today and say goodbye
to those pesky spots tomorrow that's
genucel.com
walshyt and now the makers of quiet
quitting are back with a new hit called
hashtag act your wage this is another
viral Trend which is essentially the
same thing as quiet quitting sort of
taking the Marvel approach where the
sequel is a carbon copy of the original
the ACT you're wage Trend which has
taken off on Tick Tock is apparently
best explained by this viral video which
has millions of views from Tick Tock
user Sarai Marie Let's uh take a look
know how to do your job I don't
understand what
hey Veronica I'm gonna have you take
this home and work on it tonight okay
respectfully Susan I'd rather spend time
with my family
Veronica did you just decline the zoom
meeting us at 6 30 tonight
oh yeah I did I did do that yeah because
it's outside of my working hours nine to
five so I won't be attending all right
Veronica I do need you to be available
during your vacation okay
[Music]
I've come to talk with you again okay
Veronica I'm gonna need you to complete
all this today see
like two people to you no oh okay just
making sure because that looks like the
work of two people right right and I'm
one I'm just one person right and it's
time to go home five o'clock
hey thank you bye it would appear that
uh
acting your wage means being so grating
and annoying and thrilled that you end
up sitting alone in an empty corner of
the office because everybody else has
jumped out the window
now we should first note here as we did
with the Quiet quitting Trend the
proponents of this approach do in theory
make a couple of valid points so it's
true that you should have a life outside
of work
it's also true that you need to know how
to set boundaries not just at work but
in general so you don't get taken
advantage of but both of these potential
positives are ultimately neutralized
because for one thing there is no real
value in ensuring that you have extra
time outside of work if you aren't going
to spend that extra time doing something
enriching and worthwhile I am not
chugging beer I'm sampling a flight of
gluten-free German lagers with a French
wine pairing so most of these people
will just go home and scroll through
Tick Tock that's how they're spending
their extra time
this is my opinion
who's the most what the is this we
heard in the video that Veronica wanted
to spend more time with her family but
the problem is that these days most
people in their 20s don't have families
so by family they really mean their
couch their phone and their HBO Max
subscription second setting boundaries
is important but in the adult world you
need to know how to do that with a
certain amount of tact and diplomacy we
call this a diplomatic solution no I
call it aggressive negotiations what the
video is recommending is that employees
act like a bunch of spoiled toddlers
turning up the smarmy level to 100
screeching like overgrown bats and
acting uh offended their boss would even
ask them to do a little bit extra so you
can't it's what you have to understand
kids you cannot talk to your boss that
way you might you might wish that you
could but you can't what is wrong with
you people and if you if you've made
yourself Expendable that's going to be a
problem for you and making yourself
Expendable it's certainly one way to
approach life the other way to approach
it is to strive to be indispensable but
that takes effort and it takes Talent
and here's an important point it takes
time but here's the good news if you're
a younger person and you're just
starting out in your career the deck has
been cleared okay many of your peers are
are settling for mediocrity already they
haven't even tried yet
and they've decided there's no point in
trying this is an opportunity for you
if you're not one of those people as
long as you have slightly more fortitude
and a slightly better work ethic than
all those other losers you have an
opportunity and that'll do it for today
[Music]